jürgen häberle court 30 jahre alt er
ringt nach luft das röntgenbild zeigt
warum das milchige ist eine massive
lungenentzündung schwellungen und
flüssigkeit versperren der luft den weg
hämmerle droht zu ersticken seine organe
sind am ende ihrer kraft die zeit läuft
golde auf treatment letztendlich das in
der ersten stunde so viel passiert wie
möglich um die organfunktionen zu
übernehmen und zu stabilisieren dieser
coup 19 fall ist simuliert der ablauf
ist echt ein lehrfilm der uniklinik
tübingen
auftritt kabel und schläuche es sind
sehr viele hämmerle wird sediert
schlafen gelegt was mit ihm passiert
soll er nicht miterleben etwa dass ihm
der anästhesist gleich einen schlauch
durch den mund in die luftröhre schiebt
hierüber hat mit ab jetzt eine maschine
für den patienten
wir beatmen zunächst einmal um produktiv
natürlich das heißt wir versuchen die
lunge so weit zu schonen die es möglich
ist in dem wir eben die atemarbeit
übernehmen dustin platziert nun katheter
in venen und arterien 20 bis 30
zentimeter sind sie lang eingeschoben
anhalts und leiste ultraschall hilft
dabei die katheter messen was tief im
körper vor sich geht reichen bis ins
herz hinein weitere sonden kommen hinzu
etwa in magen und blase
hämmerle wird mit medikamenten geflutet
sie ernähren ihn führen ab steuern
herzschlag und blutdruck andere
verhindern gerinnsel bekämpfen bakterien
dazu kortison narkosemittel flüssigkeit
die patienten
können nebenwirkungen allein durch diese
medikamentöse therapie aber sie müssen
das abwägen mit dem fakt dass die
patienten wahrscheinlich ohne diese
therapie nicht überleben würden ein
britischer arzt hat dieses bild gepostet
soviel medikamente bekommt ein qubit 19
patient auf intensiv pro tag keines
davon hilft gegen kuwait 19 uhr gegen
die symptome wir nennen das support tief
also unterstützen das ganze ist eine
subjektive therapie die heilung muss
letztendlich vom patienten selbst auf
seinem körper kommen doch himmelskörper
ist so schwach seine lunge leidet unter
der beatmung eine häufige komplikation
jetzt hilft nur noch die eco eine
maschine die das blut aus dem patienten
heraus pumpt und es mit sauerstoff
belädt außerhalb des körpers solange die
ecke läuft braucht der patient seine
lunge nicht mehr sie kann sich erholen
ein hoch riskanter eingriff
gleichzeitig ist es so dass diese
patienten durch den geringen
sauerstoffkonzentration relativ schnell
innerhalb von 12 stunden versterben
würden
weil sie einfach ihre organfunktionen
nicht mehr aufrechterhalten können das
müssen sie gegeneinander abwägen
natürlich unterlaufen der ethno und bei
vollem bewusstsein beginnt hämmerles
physiotherapie im film nach einer stunde
in der realität dauert das alles wochen
im idealfall sieht die lunge dann wieder
so aus
normal hämmerle hat es also geschafft
einen schweren verlauf überlebt knapp
jeder zweite ähnlich erkrankte hat
dieses glück nicht und wer überlebt ist
noch lange nicht gesund
also das schwere lungen versagen macht
etwas mit den patienten der umbauprozess
in der lunge führt dazu dass sie weniger
leistungsfähig sind eventuell es
vielleicht auch die herzfunktion mit
beeinträchtigt so dass eine ganze reihe
dieser patienten hinterher auch sehr
viel therapie benötigen nur ein drittel
aller patienten kehrt in ein normales
leben zurück alle anderen müssen sich
auf ein neues ein eingeschränktes leben
einrichten